Jack Kirby was one of the principle minds
and artists behind some of the best known
comic characters in history, including, among
many others, the Fantastic Four, the Hulk,
X-Men, and Captain America.
Few people realise, though, that like his
most patriotic creation, Kirby spent a good
portion of WW2 fighting the Nazis as well,
though never managing to duplicate Captain
America’s feat of punching Hitler in the
face.
Kirby was drafted into the army in June of
1943, just as his comic career was starting
to gain some serious traction, and was initially
assigned to be trained as a mechanic.
However, according to Kirby’s son, Neal,
his father had absolutely no affinity for
the finer points of mechanics and spent as
much of his training as possible lying below
a truck and occasionally smacking it with
a wrench so that it sounded like he was doing
something.
In a rare set of interviews given by Kirby
in the early 1990s, he revealed that one of
the most surprising things about basic training,
other than the difficulty of the training
itself in those days, was the culture shock
of meeting so many people from so many different
backgrounds he previously knew little about.
“There were very limited communications:
A telephone was very hard to come by, not
like today.
To own an automobile you had to be semi-rich,
and nobody ever took a cab; those were taken
by rich people too.
And airplanes?
We all took trains back then and you only
went on a train when you really had to go
someplace.”
One anecdote Kirby remembered fondly was the
time he introduced himself to a Texan as a
Brooklyn native and the Texan asked him “What’s
a Brooklyn?”
Likewise, Kirby also expressed shock at hearing
a southern accent for the first time, formerly
believing that the accent was simply a product
of Hollywood that must have been exaggerated
in some way.
He stated, “In that particular way, I think
the war did a lot for uniting America; it
was a galvanizing experience.
It united the states because it forced people
to work and live in close quarters with each
other; it forced us to meet each other on
common terms…”
jack-kirby3After his basic training, Kirby
was shipped off to what was then known as
Burma (Myanmar today) where he was given training
in how to become an anti-aircraft gunner.
Training for this included a live fire exercise
in which a gunner crew was asked to shoot
at banners and flags hung several hundred
feet behind a friendly tow plane.
It’s noted that Kirby’s anti-aircraft
crew were so bad at this that they shot down
their own friendly pilot, causing him to have
to bail out.
Unsurprisingly, Kirby was soon reallocated
to an infantry division in Eastern Europe
where he joined the 11th Infantry Regiment.
During his time with the 11th Infantry, Kirby
and his fellow soldiers were subjected to
no less than 36 separate assaults from the
German army while trying to hold a small section
of wood bordering the Moselle River in the
North of France.
One notable assault attempt included a large
tank that smashed through the regiment’s
defensive line, only to be stopped by an unnamed
soldier managing to shoot through the driver’s
viewing slit, killing him instantly and potentially
saving the life of Kirby who was only feet
away from its treads in a foxhole.
During another firefight, Kirby got an odd,
seemingly crazy order from another soldier.
He later recounted the story,
“Once during a fight some guy crawled up
to me from the back and he grabbed my feet.
I almost shot his head off.
He said to me, ‘Pick out five men and go
see Marlene Dietrich.’…
I was at the end of this rock wall and chunks
of it were flying around from 88 shells, the
earth around me was going up in big clots,
all the rest was being pounded by machine
guns, and I was laying there talking to this
big jerk…
This guy said, ‘If you don’t want the
detail then I’ll get another guy.’
I said, ‘All right, all right.
I’ll take the detail.’
I still didn’t believe this guy, but I picked
out five other guys—they thought I was crazy
too—and they came along with me.
We crawled about 100 yards and walked another
400 where there was a truck waiting and other
GIs were getting on.
So these other guys and me got on this truck
and they took us about 7 miles down the road
away from the action.
And sure enough, there she was, Marlene Dietrich,
along with Bing Crosby, Martha Raye, and some
other actors.
They put on a show for us; comedy, Vaudeville
acts, singing, dancing—all that in this
hell on Earth.
I couldn’t believe it, the guys with me
couldn’t believe it—our jaws must have
dropped and hit the ground.
After a while I wasn’t even thinking about
the friggin’ war.
At one time Marlene Dietrich came out in GI
underwear and it was crazy as all hell.
Meanwhile the Germans had deepened their defense
and some of the fire reached this little theatre
they had set up.
A shell hit not far away, I felt the concussion,
and we all expected to be called back to the
action, but the show went on.
Bombs fell closer and gunfire got clearer,
and all the while these actors kept the show
going as if nothing else mattered.
It was a real morale booster for us.
It upped my respect for these performers immensely;
for all performers everywhere—they were
really what they said they were, real troupers.
There they were right up near the line; I
mean, how far is 7 miles?
They took the risk almost as much as the soldiers
did.”
Kirby’s position while serving with the
regiment was that of a scout, regarded as
one of the most dangerous jobs a soldier could
have.
His basic duties involved sneaking ahead into
unknown territory and drawing maps for the
allies to use.
Kirby would later recall of all this, “If
somebody wanted to kill you, they made you
a Scout.
So, I was a Scout.”
So how did he get the unenviable gig?
According to Kirby, he became a Scout shortly
after a Lieutenant learned his last name and
asked if he was the Jack Kirby.
Kirby enthusiastically responded “Yes sir.
I drew Captain America,” believing that
the Lieutenant probably just wanted his portrait
drawn or something.
Instead, the Lieutenant, now knowing about
Kirby’s artistic abilities, made him a Scout,
telling him “You go into these towns that
we don’t have and see if there is anybody
there.
Draw maps and pictures of what you see and
come back and tell us if you find anything.”
During one scouting mission, Kirby recalled
that he was started by a rustling noise only
to find it was just a dog.
It was a great big hound that was badly injured;
it was cut and burned all over…
It stopped in front of me and just stared.
It didn’t growl or whimper, it just looked
at me with these deep accusing eyes; it was
the most human expression I have ever seen
on an animal.
It was like he was saying, “You, you did
this to me!”
Oh, I felt so guilty.
I felt just terrible and so hurt, because
to me it was like an accusation by a dumb
creature that didn’t care why I was there
or anything about the Germans.
All he knew was that I was there and he was
hurting; that’s all this animal knew.
All this was happening around him and even
though I had nothing to do with it, I’m
still the cause.
I didn’t have the courage to look this beast
in the eyes any longer.
I lowered my rifle and it limped past me out
of the wreckage and onto the road.
He kept giving me these dirty looks, terrible
dirty looks.
I think I stood there for several more minutes
before I continued my sweep.
On another occasion, he got into a fire fight
with a German soldier who’d made fun of
his mother.
Most Americans have an image of war—especially
that war—that it was a carefully planned
event; groups of men—groups of professional
fighting men—going up against other professional
soldiers, moving in columns, aiming their
rifles, all under the orders of their commanding
officers.
Well, let me say that guys are guys no matter
what the circumstances may be and different
rules apply.
We called each other names all the time; we
were cursing each other in English, German,
French, Hebrew; I had quite a large vocabulary
by the time I got back—I could cuss somebody
out in four different languages.
Sometimes a shot was never fired but we’d
still be yelling at each other to ‘go to
hell’ or ‘go sh*t on yourself’; but
you never said anything about somebody’s
mother, not unless you wanted somebody to
take a potshot at you.
And that’s exactly what he did,
I entered a street and somebody from a window
started calling me all kinds of names in German,
and he was laughing.
“I’m going to kill you,” he said.
“I’m going to shoot you right in the face.”
I stepped back against the wall and pulled
back the bolt on my machine gun.
I was ready to wait this guy out, but then
he said something about my mother.
I forget what, but it gets me pissed—I mean
really pissed—so I stood back and began
spraying where this voice has been calling.
Then he started spraying me and soon the whole
street is riddled with bullets.
I guess there was more than one guy because
I could hear them running through the buildings.
We all ran like hell, but I never saw these
guys.
I think I hit two of them, but I didn’t
stick around to count.
I ran like crazy, the whole place was filled
up with flying stuff.
There’s also a persistent rumor that Kirby
ambushed three Nazis and killed them all with
a knife, but Kirby himself never confirmed
this story in any of the interviews he gave
about his time in the war, nor could we find
any well documented evidence to support the
rumor, so the veracity of the tale is somewhat
questionable.
jack-kirby2Kirby’s military service came
to an end when he got frostbite on both of
his feet during an unforgiving European winter.
“Don’t think I just got nippity-ippity
frozen—they were frozen.
It took them a year to even get back some
of the original color.”
After spending this year recovering and barely
avoiding having his feet amputated, Kirby
was sent home.
Funny enough, Kirby missed the transport ship
meant to take him home in a mere three day
journey because he got a cold.
As a result, he had to return to the states
in a lumbering hospital tug boat.
To add insult to injury, he noted that he
mostly starved on the nine day trip back,
suffering from intense sea-sickness that made
it almost impossible to keep any food down.
Though he didn’t complain, “many men lost
limbs, some lost part of their faces.
I saw guys with half a face; one you could
look inside part of his head.
And I saw a lot of guys who were scarred deeply
in other ways.
Listen, I was doing all right compared to
most of the other guys.”
He went on to say, “There is nothing that
you would call romantic about war.
Sure, in the movies and on television they
paint a great picture of the fellowship that
it creates.
I’ve seen war bring lots of people together,
but I can tell you that the cost is extremely
high: Not just in terms of lives, but in the
human spirit.
I think that we are diminished by war; our
character as a race is somehow reduced by
each war that we allow to happen.
Hitler had to be destroyed, there was no choice
and I was glad to do my duty—but if there
were another way to bring him down I would
have preferred it.”
After returning to the states, Kirby picked
up his career where it had left off and went
on to become one of the most prolific comic
creators in history.
As famed comic book artist Gil Kane noted
of Kirby,
Jack was the single most influential figure
in the turnaround in Marvel’s fortunes from
the time he rejoined the company … It wasn’t
merely that Jack conceived most of the characters
that are being done, but … Jack’s point
of view and philosophy of drawing became the
governing philosophy of the entire publishing
company and, beyond the publishing company,
of the entire field … [Marvel took] Jack
and use[d] him as a primer.
They would get artists … and they taught
them the ABCs, which amounted to learning
Jack Kirby.
… Jack was like the Holy Scripture and they
simply had to follow him without deviation.
That’s what was told to me … It was how
they taught everyone to reconcile all those
opposing attitudes to one single master point
of view.
Kirby was born Jacob Kurtzberg before changing
his name to Jack Kirby, which he reportedly
chose because it reminded him of Jimmy Cagney,
an actor he was fond of.
There’s also a rumor that Kirby changed
his name because his original name sounded
“too Jewish”, but Kirby himself has always
denied this.
In 1979, Jack Kirby teamed up with the CIA
and the make-up artist from Planet of the
Apes as part of something now known as “The
Canadian Caper”.
In a nutshell, Kirby was asked to create a
bunch of concept art for a non-existent sci-fi
movie called Argo which was used as cover
to rescue some hostages.
This story was later adapted into the Oscar
winning, albeit wildly inaccurate, film starring
Ben Affleck.